well there's uh just a couple days left
until Christmas and of course you'll see
the Salvation Army out and about
throughout the Las Vegas Valley doing
their good work yeah for decades
agency and they hope to do the same this
year Christian cozidis has the story
it's been a huge blessing to see people
and I I can imagine it's tough for some
of those people to put a few dollars
into the kettle but they do it because
they know that there are others who are
less fortunate
as the Salvation Army of Southern Nevada
wraps up this year's red Kettle campaign
Captain Ryan Burchell reminding everyone
about the impact from every dollar the
donations that we receive here at
Christmas time are a huge percentage of
the funding that we use for our family
assistance programs whether it be for
food whether it be for after school care
and programs you know whether it be for
individual assistants homeless
assistance for over 100 years the
Salvation Army has rolled out the red
Kettle during the holidays to help the
community this year volunteers have
fanned out across the valley at 40
locations hoping to meet their 500 000
goal
this season has been especially
difficult for people and and we we
understand that we definitely get that
that's why you'll see our volunteers
never fully approaching somebody you
know trying to hassle anybody Captain
Rochelle says Las Vegas is an amazing
City and has seen how the community
steps up to help each other he adds
every donation and big or small is a
blessing
that brings a smile on my face when I
think about that and I see uh whether it
be a child or or you know a a senior vet
or anybody else in between you know
people who are uh giving of what they
have you know we we don't take it for
granted